whereas to find a power series for F and
they've given us f of X is equal to 6
over 1 plus X to the third power now
since they're letting us pick which
power series you might see well let me
just find the Maclaurin series because
the Maclaurin series tends to be the
simplest to find because we're centered
at 0 and so you might immediately go out
and say alright well let me evaluate
this function at 0 evaluates derivative
at 0 its second derivative 0 so on and
so forth and then I can use the formula
for the Maclaurin series to just expand
it out but very quickly you will run
into roadblocks because the first the
evaluating this at F at x equals 0 is
pretty straightforward evaluating the
first derivative is pretty
straightforward but then once you start
taking the second and third derivatives
it gets very hairy very fast you could
do a simplification where you could say
well let me find the Maclaurin series
for F of U is equal to 6 over 1 plus u
where u is equal to X to the 3rd so you
find this Maclaurin expansion in terms
of U and then you substitute for X to
the 3rd and actually that makes it a
good bit simpler so that is another way
to approach it but the simplest way to
approach it is to say hey you know this
this form right over here this rational
expression it looks similar it looks
like the sum of a geometric series let's
just remind ourselves what the sum of a
geometric series looks like if I have a
plus a times R so a is my first term R
is my common ratio plus I'm going to
multiply times R again plus a times R
squared plus a times R to the third
power and I keep going on and on and on
forever we know that this is going to be
equal to a our first term over 1 minus
our common ratio and this comes from a
the sum of a geometric series and notice
that what we have here are f of x our
definition of f of X and the sum of a
geometric series look very very similar
if we say that this right over here is a
so a is equal to 6 and if negative R is
equal to X to the third or we could say
let me
rewrite this I could write this
denominator is 1 minus negative x to the
third and so now you can say okay well R
could be equal to negative x to the
third and just like that we can expand
it out well if a is equal to 6 and Nate
and R is equal to negative x to the
third well then we can just write this
out as a geometric series which is very
straightforward so let's do that
and I will do this in I'll just in this
nice pink color so the first term would
be 6 plus 6 times our common ratio 6
times negative x to the third and so
actually let me just write that as
negative 6x to the third and then we're
going to multiply by negative x to the
third again so that's going to be if I
multiply this times negative x to the
third that's going to be positive six
times X to the sixth power and I'm going
to multiply about times negative x to
the third again so it's going to be
minus 6 times X to the ninth power and
I'm going to go on and on and on so it's
going to be and then I could keep going
on multiply times negative x to the
third I will get 6x to the twelfth power
now we can go on and on and on and on
forever and so the key here was and this
is the Maclaurin series expansion for
our f of X but the key is to not have to
go through all of this business and just
to recognize that hey the way this
function was defined is it looks a lot
like the sum of a geometric series and
it can be considered the sum of a
geometric series and we can use that to
find the power series expansion for our
function this is a very very very useful
trick